is Nevada state police saying NCAA and
Taylor Swift are prompting extra Patrol
Ryan Matthey joining us live outside of
allegiant Stadium where an early
merchandise sale is currently underway
okay
yeah Brian Kirsten are you ready for it
the Fearless crowds that are expected
here this weekend of course you and I
both know those crowds all too well but
the music and sporting fans leaving no
blank space on our roads and Troopers
telling drivers you need to calm down
over a hundred thousand swifties
and thousands of basketball fans more
this weekend yes we are anticipating a
high volume of Tours coming to town
across Southern Nevada extra Troopers
scheduled to patrol both in town
and near the California state line says
Trooper Ashley Wellman we're bringing
Troopers in for overtime specifically
for this weekend to do uh driving Under
the Influence another Grant that's
funded by Officer Traffic Safety as well
as the speed from joining forces 10 to
15 Troopers typically scheduled for a
swing shift she says this weekend it's
doubled
but those traffic headaches could
consume the southern strip especially
with ongoing Tropicana construction
nearby and the close proximity of the
two venues
at T-Mobile Arena MGM Resorts and the
NCAA expecting 19
000 people Saturday Taylor Swift is my
mother an early merchandise sale outside
Allegiant Stadium Thursday giving a
glimpse of the 50 to 55 000 Taylor Swift
fans expected per night on Friday and
Saturday fans like Emily oofway are
planning ahead I scheduled a lift for
after the show to pick me up
to help with that probably will still
sit in traffic but I'll at least like be
in a car and not just like sitting on
the sidewalk
now MGM Resorts is directing basketball
fans to park at any MGM property
Allegiant Stadium they have limited
parking there are two Rideshare Lots
located just across the freeway as you
see here it's both at the Luxor and
Mandalay Bay and that is acceptable or
accessible rather by walking over the
Hacienda bridge for now reporting live
outside Allegiant Stadium Brian mathie 8
news now it is acceptable as well Ryan
you were correct Ryan also reached out
to Metro Police to ask about their plans
a spokesman told him quote it's like any
other night in Las Vegas State Police
urging drivers slow down pay attention
and plan accordingly if drinking